[Music]
I was dreaming
Oh, oh, oh
, please wake up The groom and the
bride are ready
I met you on
that dreamy day
I tend to be arrogant, but actually it's different. From the
yakiniku set meal to the yakiniku, you get miso soup and pickles for the price of 200 cultivars and a single rice item.
Big unboxing
give me
[music]
dewan
ku ana aname
dee
[music]
paipan
extension dan
ni
t
[music]
n ame
ana
ani
[applause]
I like you uni
[music] It
's not our school
uniform Why did this happen
I was first, but the seat next to me is vacant Please take a picture of me.
Udo for 250 yen Ebiken for 150 yen and squid tempura for 100 yen Kashiwa store Satsuma teru On top of
that, chastity and Fukui
Kyu celebrities go to celebrities such as students and celebrities
.
Are you studying in the middle of the day?
Music] It's
frustrating, isn't it? I'm not good at studying, so I'm jealous.
Shall I share a little bit with
you?  It seems like you're looking for a suitable tutor for your daughter Tutor It's a
homey and fun workplace, and it pays five times the market price
.
I was able to do it, but
with this  You'll be able to eat to your heart's content Onii-chan,
what kind of person is that girl? She's a
high school student, and if I remember correctly, she said she's going to transfer to her onii-chan's school
.
A book that doesn't exceed normal uniforms isn't a black rose Are you serious?
Anesthesia
Yes Yakiniku set meal Without yakiniku
I failed yesterday
If that transfer student rejected me, the
tutor story would be gone
Somehow the Aizu issue Makimin
I came lined up to save me
Of course it's just rice  I
made you wait for a minute I'm eating with my friends,
but it's already full ame
I'm going
to like it I guess Mi-chan is the target, isn't it?
You seem to like it,
I'll read
it for you,
too.
Hey, you're in the
same grade
Taboo,
but I'm in trouble It's been a while since I put my
mother together as a tutor with Ice
Cream
Oh, oh, oh, I
finally want to see this
[music]
Buber lesson That's it
ame
At that time,
I noticed
[music]
ana,
which one?
[Music]
Kamiji-san's Minister's Award seems to be a friend in the dark, but I'm going to
give you a new genius.
Thank you I don't even know about that in 6 of the repayment
Now I've picked it all up
Haha I
'm happy with this Thank you I've gone
tai
I don't have the
time to apologize I'm
having fun alone
This is my hobby
Hmmm
Watching school girls is a hobby
Parents passing by stand up and tell my
friend Juri I understand But she's
a friend
[music]
Ko  I
'm not rich from the radio here, but
there's no doubt
[Music]
If Naruki has something to post, I'll listen to it, but
Omae and others are talking about it.
This is my house, but seriously I'm sorry
Yakiniku set meal without yakiniku I'm on a
diet
[ __ ]
ran
me
1 This is the
last chance to call out
Well, it's coming
[music]
Day 4
Haa
[music] It's
all about my dog, even for red's sake  Even though
I'm sweating and running in a place like this between schools, I've already put up 6 cases
jal I'm sorry
4th
tan The
whole school
hurried up
What are
you?
What do you mean, why did you come here and
if there is no way to break the orbit
, mix it with dharma What do you want to do?
It's
delicious I don't like the car with the band I don't like it,
but I can't give up
Hey
, I think I was completely at fault for yesterday I'm sorry
From today I'm your partner
Ti is this kind of person
Don't be our tutor, it's
me
[Music] The
star in front of the apartment just now is super dare amaran
If you say this, Fei-kun Eater 2 Tones
are too many, please hurry up and fly
3 Why are these guys
living red meat?  It's already decided, isn't it?
Five of my classmates and I shared a house.At
this time, my brain was suddenly overloaded, writing at a speed that exceeded its limit, and
one of them came up with an answer.
That's why it's not close No,
oh,
it's the end of us at five
From today, I'm Futaro Uesugi, who became your tutor.
Give me a
wrinkle today
[music]
This guy is
amazing  Why are you in there
?  It's my turn. From the
point of collecting the former palace,
Itsuki is a very serious girl
who says it's
okay.  I wonder if there's even one of us here.I'm not sure
what to do yesterday.I want you to teach me how to
study.Please don't come here.
Is born
Iyo
Why did my classmate's girl go to the town of
Tanopo?  Just
like that, please don't be surprised
What is this room?
I'm
embarrassed because I'm not wearing any clothes.
I came to my classmate's girl's room, but that's fine
Ah,
somehow change your clothes quickly and come over now
[Music]
Only Utaro has something I want to ask.
No
, it was just now
Boo Taro is
coming You can just say "No thunder
"
Don't worry, I'm studying
[music]
Why don't I go out
?
Cookies don't have poison even if you don't carry them with youー
If you eat them, you don't have to worry about studying
We
don't really need a private tutor, you know? pandan
[music]
Hmm, yes, no
lie 39
It's a natural reaction from these guys, but I told them
that the only way was to let them graduate.
Oh, my dear
customer, I've got a customer.
Boy,
where is the
customer's house?
You showed me your student
handbook What is that photo 3?
Mmm Ito store, maybe it's not a center, so I can buy it
[Music]
If you don't mind, I can't eat at my house.
That
's right, huh o I asked the lady if she could understand the taste of the common people
Oh, that's why I looked at you and you were so kind to me Even if it was a snack, I didn't expect you to bring a girl
Big brother
, I came here with my tutor
. It's about that. Of course, it's a
badge.  Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh
oh  I'm
hungry after using my head, so please treat me again
[Music]
Don't get me wrong, I understand your situation, but I can't cooperate
.
I'll
do it
without
borrowing a tutor.  Please collect the
[  Music]
That's
right Conditions, etc. Graduation of all the people
Nothing stupid To be honest,
there's no need to deal with everyone like this All
you have to do is look at the candidate for the red mark
Hey
, the five of us transferred to another school after failing
[music]
That's right, I dream
of that
moment even when
I grow up  The total weight of 250 kg can be divided into 5 years.